welcome to this video playing sony away
sony away from that hard to miss egypt
yeah it's very difficult to see this
real in the middle of it I think it's a
wheel um okay let's see what we get hmm
I could play the green fault it's black
don't do that too often and it's really
a good opening and so let's see I don't
really I don't really know it too well
but maybe in 15 minute I can I can
manage somehow you always do that at
some point of c-5 must be okay and here
kids castles hmm
Queen a5 sis I think the main move now
22i will see two okay yeah but there is
lots of pressure now one on them on
before I ever take it here Bishop takes
you would need to take with the night
now that's weird maybe this first is the
best though I'm threatening now to take
on d4 d5 there is c3 hanging and I don't
really see what whites movers maybe
rocky one but itself let's like them I
have lots of pressure on the center
young I think Queen d2 is absolutely the
way to go
yeah I'm threatening to take the pawn
okay maybe this is a very good way to to
to try to to to play this position let's
consider hmm take it pawn takes and then
queen to be six yeah looks pretty good
it's a time to defend the center I think
hmm he's got a rupee one though wow this
was still why why did I play this took
reclaim rugby 190 form hmm Queen a
forecheck Bishop d7 maybe this as
possible okay he didn't he didn't go for
that okay if I take on d4 now I can give
should be five check at the end that's
not great okay I just I just guessing
here now rook be one there really is no
ID form because there's no check or
anything and I have Bishop f5 with the
tempo and this looks this looks
excellent don't need to do anything more
complicated okay Bishop f5 with this to
get this tempo in or Bishop g4 maybe
Bishop g4 actually yeah come on maximize
the pressure on g4 yeah now I can
actually take here take on deform okay
I'll do that at the end of this opponent
a very nice position so I maybe even two
points know that I think of it
he after take stakes he cannot really
take on b7 as a one is saying so he
needs to spend him 11 castling and I
said maybe two points because I can
maybe try to keep be seven volts so
winning e5 not sure if it is a good idea
though yeah move like rook b8 that looks
yet to come on let's just take this this
should be really fine the Nile another
nice feature of this position is that
the pawn is still on only seven so I
have a nice post for the bishop on f6 or
d6 very safely anchored cannot be
attacked and
yeah there is no no technical reputation
I think it looks a bit bit strange to to
get into this gal that's almost a pin in
a way but no way to at least I don't see
it at the moment to to use it at it to
use it directly young bishops five
Quincy five I mean of course or anything
else now it's a bit difficult here to
get the rooks interplay okay come on
I'll play the anthem but it is not it is
opposite colored bishops but with rooks
on so it's probably maybe not the best
way to play but it should still be
excellent ok so maybe rook v6 or taking
a look at the age
maybe try that maybe it takes that that
would be helpful yep now I have the
bishop on c5 which covers be six and
seven let that's very nice actually okay
so what's my next step I need to
activate the rook how exactly five and
age 5 root G a G for or something like
that yeah I shouldn't really have it
shouldn't have gone to the same game but
but ok so it's still very nice for black
but not a very easy win
I can give this checklist it's not
really lead to anything
hmm
try to keep pawns on the board what I
really didn't appreciate is that eid
that he gets the D file this was this
was really stupid allowing that the very
bad technical play by black ok give me
here maybe you can get in Bishop g4
whoopsie age something like that if I
get my look into play I'm I'm okay rook
you won this King F form
yummm knock up here and rook c8 next
so I i was able to oh it will be able to
activate activate the rook yeah kicking
it is really a complete a draw I guess
and very likely very likely to be a tool
to draw bishops III then contending king
deform ok king before or is this running
into some sort of trouble can you form a
king d for rookie forecheck King d3 yeah
but don't don't see a big problem with
it at the moment check
there is no check now Bishop c2 c4 or
covered yeah so at least my king was
activated and now Bishop d2f for maybe
and Roxy one this kind of improvement
would would really mean something okay
so it's trying to enter here I guess so
I cover that for the moment the
seventh-ranked I mean
who came and now just here covering g5
intending Bishop f4 and Roxy one of
course our Bishop e3 Roxy want this kind
of ideas now that gets that that's
getting tricky now provide maybe there
still is some decent setup but it's not
easy okay Bishop f4 or III actually but
should be three it's not bad it covers
b6 it covers g5 yeah that's good and
that intense looks you want as mentioned
so now Roxy one down there is no no
particular counter play the idea is rook
g1 check King edge to look everyone
winning f3 there is Bishop c4 check
though this is very important shouldn't
run into that
hmm yeah not sure but let him make a
move it's not it's not so easy really um
maybe this Bishop c4 is is really a bit
tricky now the b5 it's not really not
really great
the whole thing is actually more
effective with the bishop here now that
I think of it because it prevents Bishop
c4 he cannot play FYI Mia just take it
rook takes Bishop b5 and picks up the
rook so there is no disadvantage and I
have this check and now rook f1 and I
don't see what he's doing besides wait
wait wait wait wait this Bishop see to
bishop see to check I have King c3
though yeah I have Kingsley three
resistances in fact the easiest kingi to
this rook f2 now that that's okay that's
okay really Bishop c 2 i've got King c3
that's important I really don't want to
calculate a look and gambits probably
yeah it's a very good room and game yeah
Bishop egger can take it it's not fatal
anything take it rook takes d4 Luke
takes a three exits it's excellent but
if I just go here if I just go here he
has no move really there's the same
thing on f3 it's not you cannot cover it
and I'm threatening look f2 takes it
takes leadership so this is much easier
technically okay the check first yeah
it's a bit more precise check so that I
actually take f3 with a tempo that age 3
is hanging again
the one that the question is however how
do I actually win it I mean it's very
nice to have won the second porn but how
do I win it is a rook trade winning
not sure if your trade winds
look III is the way to trade rooks yeah
but he has got this ideas like Bishop a
48 and so on it's very likely winning
but I don't really I don't really want
to check that let's Jack keep it on the
board and now where exactly just hear me
yeah just 32 and let's let's check now
how to how to make progress I can try
yeah but how exactly i wanted to second
try to set the pawns in motion but i
don't see exactly how i can i can do
that okay i'll start with this year rook
f1 though ok I've got Bishop f2 but
that's not ideal
Bishop f2 there is I can I can ok this
is ok if you go so the second-ranked I
can play Bishop g3 Bishop to have four
ok it's not so easy to move there for
the upon that sets the main technical
problem but maybe I can maybe I can just
now go back with the King and let's say
to e5 and then push at five yeah I have
this one check getting to F for keeping
the F porn protected
check
okay let's let's see how to do that
maybe now I should just really slowly
prepare a five kingi 5 + f5 this is just
just the way to go nothing particularly
fancy okay yeah this is this is helping
okay I would have liked to to show how
the land games winning without and
blundering but what can you do a cannot
I cannot not play Bishop his reasons so
my idea was if he plays some and nothing
moves or normal move him let's say I
don't know what exactly it's good thing
like that my idea was to play this and
push f5 and this should should should
end the game in a way I threatened to
take on g4 and that will get passes at
the moment the problem is that i don't
have easily am advancing on passed pawns
but after f5 i will i will get that
however i played a really bad game here
technically um I really when I went for
all this I really hadn't realized that
he has got the only open file and this
is just totally unnecessary to get I
mean here I should just keep the Queen's
on and play this position it's it's also
an excellent middle game there's no use
to there's no need to which wich reh
queen so here i can for example go him
not there i can go to deform very strong
square and then support the bishop with
e5 this would immensely strengthen my
position the bishop on d4 is covering a
seven it's covered in e five and it's
very nicely cemented in the middle
the board if you're just just for
example this kind of this kind of
situation just to show the general setup
this is just excellent the bishop here
is just a beast em it discovered it
covers e5 it covers a 7 there is nothing
that white can attack and I can try to
just on the dark squares increase the
pressure on their to pawn like this for
example or push on the kingside White
has absolutely zero counter play and
this is why keeping the Queensland would
have been much better this was really a
bad move the Queen trade yeah okay well
like it's still better call of course
but it's not not totally clear cut still
maybe there's some there was some
interesting moments I mean this is
pretty instructive you shouldn't trade
pawns here H flow is just a good move
because in the long run those pawns will
be will be targets and you shouldn't
exchange any of them and we see much
later that detect f3 fell and aged three
years own check was close to 2 2 to fall
as well so this was some still a very
good endgame but well it was better to
to to play a middle game there alright
thanks for watching